こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
はい、というわけで皆さん今日はですね、わたくしはじめしゃちょーのクッキングコーナーでございます。
はいみんな拍手　ぱちぱちぱちぱち・・・
あは・・・
なぜか吐きそうですねｗｗ
よくね、知育菓子を食べるんですよね、メジャーな知育菓子といえばこれですね。
ねるねるっねとかメジャーじゃないですかね、まぁこうゆう知育菓子をですね、今回、お店にある分全種類買ってきました！
はい、といゆわけですね、はいこちらのですね、はいあ！ねるねるねるね二つあんじゃん！
がさっ！
こちらの知育菓子をですね、はい全種類買ってきたわけなんでェ、はいこの不思議な味の知育菓子を全種類混ぜるとどうゆう味になるかっていうのを、わたくし料理研究家として、はい知りたくなったわけなんですよ！
はい
とりあえずきょうは、はいこの、はい知育菓子を、はい
全部、はい混ぜてなに味になるにかっていう、はい実験的に、はいやっていこうとおもうんですけど、はいでは、はいいきましょう！はい
はいまずは、どんな知育菓子があるのか見ていきましょう。
がん！
海のいきものグミぃ～、ねるねるねるね～
カラフルラムネランド～、おえかきグミランド～
たのしいらーめんやさん～、たのしいおすしっ
(聞き取り不可能）
がさがさ。
ごそごそ。
はい、というわけでこちらの・・・こちらの7種類のですね全部まとめて一つの知育菓子を作ろうと思います。
では、いきましょう。
あっ！作る順番とかあんだよなぁ～。
ゆだんはできねェ。
ねるねるねるねに関してはそのまま食べてェ。
あぁもう取りぃ返しのつかないことになってきたぞ。
あぁらぁらぁ・・
これなんか知育菓子って水いるんだっけ・・・
めんどくさいんでコーラでいいでしょう。
どれがどれだかわかんねぇから適当でいいや。
ハサミいるし・・・
ハサミがいりますね知育菓子には。
では、いこう。
がしゃがしゃ・・・
これは、ハサミいらねぇんだな
カン、カン、カンカンカンカン
なんかちくちく、ちくちくしてきちゃった・・・
大丈夫？なんかグロいよ・・・大丈夫かなぁ？
あぁ、なんかカラフルだカラフルになってきました。
これ、成功ってことかね？
なんかできそうな気がしてきたぞ。
カンカンカンカンカン
ただのう〇〇じゃん・・・
わかる、でも何がなんの効果をもっているかちょっとわかりやすい。
これ確実に固まもん。
確実に固まりより確実なう〇〇に近ずく・・・
かなりクオリティーの高いう〇〇になっちゃった・・・
より・・凄いぞ！これで何色になるかだな・・・
ここで何色になるかで大きく多分決まると思います・・・
こうなるなんて俺も知らなかったんだよ。
軽い気持ちでやったらまぁまぁびっくり
まぁ、僕のせいじゃないかんね。
これがねぇ・・・これが現実よ。
なぁ！
子供たち見てるか？
どんな可愛いね、動物とか人間にもね闇が潜んでるってわけよ。
人の心にへばりつくわけよ。
振っても落ちないもん。
べちゃ！
あ！
じゃ、ちょっと食べてみようと思います・・・
いただきます。
なんかいろーんなしたいことが混じってるね。
ぐみにしたいけどちょっとソーダっぽい味も入れたいけど
ガムっぽくもしたいなっていう
食えないことはないな。
おいしい！
まぁまぁおいしぞ。
とりあえず今回はですね、混ぜるとこうなるっていうことを
皆さんに、お知らせしたかったわけでございます。
はい
ズゥゼェイズはじめズポイント
ぶゥるゥるゥるゥ・・・
ばん！
ろっぴやくななせんご